من اصل معنا يان انجلند الامين العام
للمجلس النرويجي للاجئين اهلا بك سيد يان
طلبتم بلا تعاقب الاونور ويعاقب سكان غزه
بما وصفته بخطا مجموعه قليله في الاونور
هناك تحذيرات بانه ربما لن تستطيع الاونور
ان تدفع حتى في شهر فبراير القادم
وبالتالي مما
تحذرون
الاونر حقيقه هي شريان الحياه لمليون من
سكان غزه وايضا من الخطا الفهم بان
المنظمات الانسانيه الاخرى من بينها التي
انا امثلها من مجلس النرويجي اللاجئين
وغيرها ممكن ان تعوض عن الانرو وتحل محلها
من دون عمليات الاونر وغزه ستنهار اذا ان
نبعد المساعدات التي
تقدمها الاونر في هذه اللحظه الزمنيه هو
تهور تماما وانا اقول ان صح بان 10 او 12
من موظفي
اونر ساهموا في هذه الانتهاكات الفظيعه
لحقوق الانسان من خلال هجمات السابع من
اكتوبر لكن قول لا تعاقبوا اطفال غزه
وسكان غزه على ما ارتكبه هؤلاء من خطا
لاننا محكومون بمبدا الحياديه فلا تحاسب
الناس على اخطاء هؤلاء باعتقادك ما الذي
يمكن فعله الان حيال مواقف هذه الدول التي
قررت وقف مساهمتها في
الاونور نحن في المجلس النرويجي للاجئين
وكثير من المنظمات الاخرى نتضامن
ونقف متضامنين مع زملائنا في الاونر الذين
يتم اتهامهم هناك الالاف منهم ما زالوا
يعملون من اجل تقديم الخدمات
للناس في مجمعات الاونر ومدارسها ومرا زها
ونحن نناشد هذه البلدان المانحه التسعه ان
لا توقف
تمويلها وانا ايضا اسال اين بلدان الخليج
الغنيه بالنفط يجب ان تهب لنجده واغاثه
سكان غزه وتساعد الامر في هذه اللحظه
عندما تقوم الحكومات الغربيه بتسييس عمليه
الاغاثه الانسانيه بعد ان حذرت محكمه
العدل الدوليه من احتمال وقوع اباده في
غزه اذا لماذا تعليق تمويل انرو انرو من
حيث الجوهر منظمه جيده قد تكون هناك بعض
القله العناصر السيئه الذين تم طردهم ولكن
هناك 300 ربما منهم اذا كان احد ع او 12
اركبوا خطا وتم طردهم فما ذنب الاخرين هل
هناك دول كما اشرت قبل قليل بامكانها ان
تعوض هذا النقص المالي في التمويل بانسحاب
هذه الدول ام ان هناك عقوبات قد تفرض
باعتبار التهم الموجهه للنور من قبل هذه
الدول كلا
لن انا بلدي النرويج اتخذت موقفا للبقاء
مع اونروا واستمرار الدعم النرويج قامت
بالامر الصواب وهي تقول ان كل الموظفين
الذين انتهكوا مبدا
الحياديه وساهموا في فضائع السابع من
اكتوبر يجب ان يطردوا ويحال على التحقيق
ويعاقبوا لكن
انرو كمساعدات تقدمها للابرياء من الاطفال
والنساء والعائلات
ستستمر النرويج بتقديمها وامل من بلدان
الخليج ان تزيد من دعمها لان بلدان الخليج
لم تتحلى بالمسؤوليه فكانت تقدم وتتراجع
تقدم وتتراجع يجب ان تقدم دعما ممنهجا
ثابتا لغزه وخاصه في هذه اللحظه الزمنيه
سيد يان انجلند هل لك ان تصور لنا حجم
توقعك لحجم الكارثه اذا لم يتم المسارعه
بتوفير المال الكافي للاون وفضل الوضع
الحالي في قطاع
[موسيقى]
غزه ان العمل الاغاثي برمته سينهار لان 80
في من الاغاثه المقدمه لغزه وكل غزه الان
تعتمد تماما على المساعدات الانسانيه فكل
العمل الانساني سينهار لن تكون هناك رواتب
ولن تكون هناك اعمال اغاثه والمنظمات
الاخرى غير قادره لتحمل المسؤوليه هناك
خطا في الفهم بان الهلال الاحمر
والمجلس الرويه اللاجئين والمنظمات الايه
الاخرى ممكن ان تحل محل الاونروا لان
اونروا مسيسه هذا ليس صحيحا الاونر مؤسسه
جيده ويقومون بعمل فعال وهم منظمه كبيره
لكن
فيهم اعضاء سيئين هناك اعضاء سيئين في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وفي الجيش الاسرائيلي
وفي كل المنظمات لا تعاقب الاطفال بسبب
خطايا القله من البعض من اوسلو يان انجلند
الامين العام للمجلس النرويجي للاجئين
شكرا جزيلا لك